[Música]
les voy a preguntar esto cuando es más
feliz un perro
le voy a dar opciones cuando le estás
por dar de comer o cuando ya le diste de
comer
le voy a contar de mi perro el mándela
ya escuché la respuesta a mandela el
mándela cuando yo le estoy por dar de
comer ya se da cuenta bebe de los gestos
que hago de las aves que yo voy a buscar
que es la que abre el portón donde está
la comida y se identifica que sabe que
se viene su momento y ya está yo puedo
sí quiero estirar ese momento de
felicidad de él tratando de hacerlo
durar hasta que llegó al galpón cuando
pongo en el tacho y hace ruido y él ve
que se cargó ahí ya está en el clímax de
la felicidad le doy de comer y ahí me
abandonó
ya no le importo más ya no me quiere más
ya no me precisa más el mándela se
olvidó de mí comió y se fue a dormir la
siesta
segunda pregunta cuando más feliz mi
mujer que se llama marcela
cuando estábamos buscando una casa para
mudarnos o cuando encontramos la casa y
nos mudamos
era mucho más feliz cuando estábamos
buscando la casa conoce en ese momento
donde me manda un mail mira a esta y
mira a esta y en ésta podemos hacer este
cambio y en esta hacemos esta reforma ya
que al baño y acá la cocina no sobre
todo el baño que vemos que no sé por qué
siempre todo el baño tiene que estar
perfecto como si fuéramos a vivir en el
baño y
y ahí ahí estaba entusiasmada después
cuando vino el camión de la mudanza ya
cuando elegimos la casa donde nos íbamos
a jugar con nuestras hijas ahí ya el
nivel de felicidad era distinto y le voy
a contar para seguir con esta reflexión
lo que me pasó a mi cuadra chicos yo soy
el mayor de cinco hermanos y me acuerdo
clarito que en un momento con mi hermano
juan andrés le pedimos a mi padre una
bicicleta papá queremos una bicicleta mi
viejo tomando mate tranquilo ni se
estresó ni consultó con mi madre ni
consultó con nadie más nos dijo
tranquilamente pidan la para papá noel
tengo 47 años para un análisis de cuando
como pasó estos 40 años atrás no se
expresaba mi viejo y nosotros
esperábamos la bicicleta todo el año sin
medicación
todo el año esperamos la bicicleta
y con mi hermano juan andrés cuando
llegó esa navidad tenía que portarse
bien tenía que ir bien en la escuela
verdad yo tenía que acompañar como si el
mayor a mis hermanos tenía que llevar a
los más chicos había algunas tareas que
hacer para después tener la bicicleta
cuando llegamos al motorcito en navidad
que mi viejo siempre regalaban así había
un montoncito para los hermanos mayores
y otros montoncito para los chicos y
viejos regalaban así chau y mi hermano
se anima juan andrés va abre y era un
triciclo
y me mira y yo le digo gracias papá
porque mi viejo me había enseñado que
teníamos que decir gracias acuerdan que
antes los padres enseñaban esto
tenía que decir gracias a lo que te tocó
sea que era lo que habías pedido o no me
siguen increíble esto yo dije gracias
papá y mi viejo y tenés que compartirlo
con tu hermano
bueno y ahí aquí voy con esto que
nosotros esperábamos todo el año esa
espera tiene que ver con la felicidad no
hoy en día confundimos empacho con
felicidad es que es lo que pasa en la
sociedad actual justamente nosotros
venimos estamos metidos en lo que hoy se
llama la sociedad de la abundancia en la
sociedad la abundancia el lema es no sé
lo que quiero pero lo quiero ya y
nuestros padres fueron educados por sus
papás o sea por nuestros abuelos en la
sociedad de la pobreza en la sociedad de
la pobreza se crecía sabiendo que no se
podía lograrlo todo se disfrutaba lo
poco que se lograba me siguen se crecía
sabiendo que no se podía lograrlo todo
pero se disfrutaba lo poco que se
lograba se crecía en la esperanza y la
sociedad actual en la sociedad de la
abundancia no sé lo que quiero pero lo
quiero ya lo quiero ya cuantos dramas
tienen nuestros chicos hoy que tienen
mucho y eso mucho que tienen es poco
porque este deseo y esta ansiedad cuando
mis papás en el ejemplo que les puse
antes esperaban todo el año nos hacía
desear
nos hacía caminar en cambio hoy en día
si tapamos todos los deseos de nuestros
hijos no los dejamos desear no los
dejamos tener ilusiones tener
expectativas y los hacemos confundir
empacho con felicidad que en la manera
directa donde se tratan de los
consultorios por ansiedad y por
depresión entonces qué es lo que pasa
con los padres de hoy pasa que los
padres de hoy no educan como antes y no
digo esto en el tono de que todo tiempo
pasado fue mejor por favor no para mí no
hay tiempo más lindo que este que
estamos vivos pero los padres de hoy
estamos tan cansados tan estresados con
tanta culpa que no tenemos tiempo para
decir que no no tenemos tiempo para
educar bien con los padres de hoy se
sacan de encima los chicos y se llega al
nene papá mamá anda con tu madre
mamá mamá anda con tu padre no ejercicio
cansado
abuela me estoy yendo y se la muestra la
abuela ajá
hay que cuidar los abuelos ahora los
abuelos se está yendo que la abuela
educaba sin culpa en cambio nosotros
somos padres culpo genos que tenemos
mucho miedo que nuestros hijos no nos
quieran y que no le dedicamos tiempo
educar es cansarse amorosamente no se
puede educar descansado tu hijo es un
milagro no es un problema y tú tienes
que tener tiempo para decirle que sí y
también para decirle que no esto es
parte de los padres de hoy el cansancio
el estrés el agotamiento y como nos
damos cuenta cómo repercute esto bueno
esto repercute en lo que quiero darles
que es la fórmula de la felicidad qué le
parece
vamos arriba la fórmula de la felicidad
la fórmula de felicidad es que nuestros
hijos no vean felices a nosotros y que
tengamos nosotros el coraje de ser
adultos y ayudar a que nuestros hijos
hospeden sus frustraciones el mejor
tutorial de felicidad el mejor tutorial
de felicidad para nuestros hijos es tu
cara en la cara con que nosotros
llegamos y le decimos a nuestros hijos
no sabes lo lindo que me fue en mi
trabajo o de buscar trabajo y si preciso
mentir miento porque no tenemos derecho
a contagia los otros reyes o nuestros
hijos porque aunque les parezca mentira
nuestros hijos quieren ser como nosotros
y qué es lo que está pasando que
nosotros estamos pecando de
sobreproteger y me incluyo tengo dos
hijas martina 18 y velen de 15 nosotros
hemos sobreprotegido a nuestros padres
más de lo que nuestros padres nos sobre
protegieron a nosotros es una
generalidad y eso qué quiere decir
proteger es fantástico proteger es
cuidar las emociones de nuestros hijos
las necesidades físicas afectivas
espirituales que tienen nuestros hijos
pero sobre proteger es cuando hago algo
que el niño puede hacer o el adolescente
puede hacer por sí mismo cuando le
resuelvo algo porque estoy cansado
porque estoy apurado y no vieron que son
los papás de hoy que le atan los
cordones hasta los 5 años igual al niño
le ponen la campera eléctrico los bañan
los llevan y los traen conocen este es
el cansancio del padre que sobreprotege
sobreproteger es cuando hago algo que el
niño puede hacer por sí mismo y de esa
manera anuló su autoestima anuló su
independencia anuló su iniciativa y
anuló la confianza en sí mismo
el gran drama que tenemos hoy en día que
los padres no se bancan que sus hijos
sufran y si no sufren no crecen porque
donde hay vida hay sufrimiento pero no
en el sentido de que ojalá que sufran o
le quiere pegar a la hermana y tú le
decís no se le pega la hermana
pero vos no estabas mira no le puede
pegar un poquito no
y esa es la tarea del adulto el gran
drama que tenemos hoy es que no hay
adultos que se van en la frustración de
que tengo que decirle a mi hija no se le
pega a la hermana es normal que le
quiera pegar esa norma tengo que
ayudarlo a que a los 5 años tenga la
capacidad de autorregular sus emociones
ya los padres que sobreprotegen les
duele el posible dolor del nene antes de
que le duela vieron eso se está por caer
ya le duele y como medio me duele antes
de que le duela y yo no quiero que él
sufra lo que yo sufrí hago cosas para
que no le duela como hago cosas para que
no le duela no le duele como no le duele
no crece y si lo exilió del sufrimiento
lo exilio del aprendizaje que es el
sufrimiento trae mucho coraje precisamos
hoy para ser adultos
qué hacer entonces por eso decimos que
sobre proteger es como la nueva forma de
maltrato porque estamos entregando
chicos a la sociedad que se los comen en
dos panes lo explico porque tiene un
psiquismo frágil que después cuando en
el trabajo le dicen para el viernes 3
tenés que entregar este informe el chico
dice renuncio
no me gustó como me habló sabes vos
nunca me habla estás y papá
entonces dónde va a sacar la felicidad
de nuestros chicos y nosotros los chile
amos del aprendizaje que trae el
sufrimiento que es que se va a caer pero
gracias a que se cae va a aprender andar
en bicicleta va a aprender a manejar una
computadora va a aprender a manejarse en
el mundo por eso esto que hacer entonces
nosotros precisamos adultos y para ser
adultos precisamos dejar de ser hijos de
nuestros padres yo soy hijo si reclamo
yo soy hijo si no perdono yo soy hijo si
todavía creo que mi infancia puede ser
distinta de la que fue ser adulto es
tener el coraje y la humildad de
agradecer a nuestros viejos de que
hicieron lo que pudieron con las
herramientas que tuvieron y nosotros
llegar a casa y poder decirle a tu hijo
un beso y un abrazo pero si tiene un
capricho o si le va a pegar a la hermana
poder decirle con total tranquilidad y
con total alegría te dije que no y es no
hijo sin miedo y sin culpa no te va a
agradecer ahora lo que estamos haciendo
por ellos fíjense a nosotros cuánto
tiempo nos llevó agradecerle a nuestros
viejos muchas gracias
[Música]